s'agit certainement d'une des images
fortes de l'actualité de la journée dans
le secteur de saint-eustache ces deux
autobus rempli d'enfants qui entrent en
collision
un des deux véhicules qui s'enflamme
suffisant évidemment pour raviver bien
des craintes dans l'esprit de plusieurs
parents avec nous pour parler la
sécurité dans ce type de véhicule martin
bureau directeur général adjoint de la
fédération des transporteurs transporter
10 bien par autobus bonsoir monsieur
bureau bonsoir
comprenez vous les craintes que
pourraient avoir certains parents la vue
de ces images là et quant à la sécurité
dans les autobus qu'est ce que vous avez
à nous dire là-dessus mais évidemment ce
soir que c'est c'est toujours inquiétant
on veut pas voir nos enfants impliqués
dans un accident
surtout pas un cas qui est à bord d'un
autobus qu'à la même chose à savoir
c'est que les autobus scolaires sont
régis selon des normes de fabrication
très sévère qui décolle de transports
canada donc les véhicules sont conçu de
sorte à faire le moins de blessés
possibles à bord des véhicules
cela dit autres l'accident qui vient de
se passer là on peut féliciter les
conducteurs pour la manière qu'ils ont
évacué les véhicules avant qu'il prenne
feu donc ça
a eu aucun blessé grave parce qu'on nous
a rapporté les faits finalement on s'en
tire bien étendre les circonstances
quand on regarde les images c'est dur à
concevoir mais donc vous vous réaffirmer
que ce type de véhicule il n'y a pas de
souci la présence ou non de ceinture de
sécurité c était souvent ramené ça dans
le débat public
écoutez les ce serait se serait à
transports canada de répondre à la
question et de faire les tests adéquats
là c'est hypothétique de ds qu' il y
aurait eu moins ou pas de blessés mais
il n'y a pas eu de blessés à bord ou des
deux séminaires est-ce que les ceintures
arrêt favoriser l'évacuation oui ou non
on peut pas aussi hypothétique de perdre
à ce moment là ce sera à transports
canada de faire les tests en conséquence
puis de voir avec ce que les ceintures
régler journée ensemble le gouvernement
semble avoir fait son lit sur cette idée
là que je suis pas nécessaire dans ce
type d'autobus mais les autobus sont
conçus de façon à ce que avec le procès
de compartimentation que vous connaissez
que vous avez déjà entendu parler que ça
minimise l aelies blessures graves
est-ce que les ceintures les transports
canada avait une étude qui disait que
les ceintures pourrait aider dans
certaines dents sur des codes d'accident
comme les renversements ou des capotages
donc quand je vous dis les ceintures les
transporteurs de sécurité sont pas
contre les ceintures de sécurité avant
les autobus cas là mais je pense que
beaucoup d'autres questions à répondre
avant de légiférer en ce sens selon
lesquelles par exemple écouter jeu si on
parle de responsabilité le
à qui vient la responsabilité d'un
accident grave avec blessés si l'enfant
n'a pas attaché ou mal attachées ou la
ceinture mal ajustées donc c'est tout
des choses qu'il fallait clarifier avant
de légiférer pour que tout le monde
puisse le savoir les partis sur le même
point de comprendre la loi dans le même
sens là donc ce que vous nous dites en
sommes là c'est que pas lieu de
s'inquiéter
dans ce type d'autobus peu importe les
circonstances et rien de plus qu on
pourrait faire monsieur bureau pour
s'assurer d'encore plus de sécurité dans
ses autobus
écoutez j'avais une boule de cristal
pouvez vous dire que tel type d'accident
et c'est ce que notre souhait c'est kate
pas d'accident du tout mais ne l'état
les vrais d'un accident puis peu importe
le type de véhicule
mais sachez que les transporteurs qu'on
représente la sécurité des passagers
c'est là cela remue ses leurs impératifs
la pièce que des inspections qui se font
régulièrement pour s'assurer que la
flotte les flottes en général parce que
tout soit deux joueurs à des compagnies
privées
les propriétaires les cas de figure
varie d'une fois à l'autre
comment on s'assure que partout dans
tous les autobus scolaire qui circulent
à l'échelle du québec par exemple mais
tout est correct mais il ya des
sécurités il ya une grande de sécurité
qui se fait à tous les jours donc les
conducteurs se doivent de d'inspecter on
aperçoit une ronde avant départ long de
sécurité il son rayon l'obligation de
faire le tour du véhicule est de
constater s'il ya des des indes et des
anomalies sur des anomalies puis deux
types d'anomalies qui peut se retrouver
à des mineurs et des majeurs si c'est un
majeur le véhicule doit rester sur place
et si pour x ou y raison
le véhicule se retrouve sur les voeux
avec une défaillance majeure mais le
véhicule et retirer automatiquement de
la route et le transporteur il fait face
à dire des amendes sévères et les
chauffeurs maintenant on parle beaucoup
de cette pénurie de main d'oeuvre
est-ce que ça touche les chauffeurs
d'autobus de ce type là est ce que là
encore une fois on s'assure que les
compétences requises
elles sont au rendez vous mais il ya des
objets il ya des
des formations obligatoires on l'appelle
dans le jargon l'appelle le métier
unique donc pour dominer comme stade de
bus scolaires sont pâles pour ce type de
véhicule là c'est un quinze heures de
formation et une formation de six ans
qui est obligatoire à tous les trois ans
donc c'est une formation qui revient le
relais de conducteurs il est formé et
puis quand on regardait les processus
d'évacuation ça fait partie de cette de
cette formation l'a très bien en
espérant monsieurbureau qu'on a su
rassurer certains parents peuvent râler
parce qu'il est arrivé aujourd'hui
encore qu'on le rappelle il n'y a pas eu
de blessé grave dans cet incident marque
bureau j'en appelle directeur général
adjoint à la fédération des
transporteurs par autobus bonne soirée
merci bonsoir innovants